la norme à oudans c'était de faire trois
fois le tour du centre-ville pour
trouver une place mais depuis le 1er
octobre les clients peuvent maintenant
se garer le stationnement est devenu
payant les eurodateurs quadr la ville en
deux espaces ceux qui appartiennent à la
zone rouge pour le centreville avec 45
minutes gratuites et la zone jaune
payante dès la première heure à 90
centimes mais aussi 1h30 de gratuité
entre 1230 et
14h nous avons décidé progressivement
installer un stationnement
payant d'abord dans les rues très
commerçantes puis dans les rues
parallèles parce qu'on sait très bien
que il y a des effets de report et que
lorsqu'on met le stationnement payant
dans les rues commerçantes les voitures
vont se reporter dans les rues
parallèles ce système permet de faire
quelques courses rapides dans le
centreville pour les clients il peut
cependant devenir plus contraignant
lorsque ce dernier doit rester plus
longtemps Stéphanie Geber gérante de
rock and pink a rédigé une pétition pour
alerter sur ce
sujet j'ai des clients qui passent donc
en Tatouage des journées complète ici le
stationnement devant mon commerce pour 4
He c'est 50 €. 4h c'est pas suffisant
pour moi pour travailler j'ai des
clients il passent de 10h à 18h donc en
terme de coût pour eux c'est énorme du
côté commerçant ce nouvel aménagement
impacte leur portefeuille le tarif fait
de 715 € l'année pour les non résidents
au parking montrotti ou bien 25 à 50 €
par jour selon la zone pour le
stationnement ce budget est difficile à
tenir pour les petites entreprises on
comprends pas pourquoi euh on n'a pas
été considéré un petit peu plus comme
comme résident
euh on passe notre vie dans nos
boutiques hein du matin au soir euh bon
on fait tourner la ville euh voilà on
est un petit peu on est un petit peu en
travers quoi on est un petit peu en
travers d'avoir un un tarif aussi élevé
vraiment pour mars 2024 la mairie
prévoit une évaluation afin d'adapter
les nouveaux dispositifs aux besoins des
professionnels et des
riverins